the both of young people matter because
they make up a huge population of the
electoral and so I think it's really
important for young people to be at the
table when decisions about them are
being made and that means elekton their
electoral body people who look like them
and people who share their values and so
we really need to make sure young people
get out to vote but also making sure
that their voices are heard in Congress
I think some of the big issues for young
people on both in local communities and
nationally is gun violence education
affordable housing jobs and economic
development but also making sure that
school is affordable for young people so
they're not coming out of college with a
huge debt one of the biggest issues of
our time is gun violence and making sure
that everyone has the right to life and
so how do we change the conversation and
making sure that our elected officials
are casting their vote in a way that is
beneficial so that way no one fears
walking down the street or losing their
life to the barrel of a gun I think
young people particularly inner city
youth feel they can't trust government
and they don't think that their vote
matters young people care about what's
going on in the world they just need to
understand the value of their their vote
and making sure that elected officials
also see it as well when you think about
who has the everyday impact on the life
that you live in the policies that
impact you as a young person it's your
it's your is your state government it's
your state senator your state
representative and they really have a
large impact on the policies that are
put into play and so I would encourage
young people to find out and seek out
who are the elected officials that are
running in your communities and make
sure that those elected officials share
your values and hold them accountable I
think that is the key
if we're going to convince young people
to vote then we have to show them that
the obstacles that they're going through
the struggles and adversities that they
are experiencing are a direct
correlation to the policies and
practices that elected officials put
into place and so if we want someone to
share our values and want someone to
really fight for us as a millennial then
we have to elect the right people to
office and that starts with first
casting your vote want more download the
aj+ mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now